quelle explication vous apportez-vous à
la haine de votre mère elle vous en veut
de quoi d'après vous je crois qu'elle
m'en veut de vivre la vie qu'elle aurait
voulu
avoir Catherine Pancol vous êtes
romancière vous avez 43 ans vous êtes
marié vous avez deux petits enfants
alors vous vous avez une histoire à
votre mère très très longue pleine de
conflits et vous venez définitivement là
de rompre ou il y a 6 mois de rompre
avec elle pourquoi parce qu'on est
arrivé à un stade où j'ai vu la haine
dans ses yeux c'estd que j'ai j'ai ça a
été c'est terrible de voir la haine dans
dans les yeux de sa propre mère qui vous
a mise au monde qui qui vous a donné la
vie enfin c'est c'est quelque chose qui
me fait mal à chaque fois donc je me
suis dit là c'est fini j'arrête quoi et
je pense que si elle avait pu mais c'est
c'est dur ce que je vais dire mais mais
je l'ai vu dans ses yeux et je pense
queelle avait pu me tuer à ce moment-là
elle l'urait fait c'était comme par
hasard un moment où je sortais un livre
le dernier la vue de l'extérieur que ça
commençait à bien marcher qu' par hasard
on était ensemble ce qui nous arrive
très très rarement parce qu'on se voit
pas beaucoup et que dans à chaque fois
que qu'il y a quelque chose de bien qui
m'arrive elle ne le supporte pas elle
c'est comme si je lui volais un truc à
elle que ça lui appartenait et que
c'était sur moi que ça tombait et là
quand j'ai vu ce regard mais de folie
c'est j'ai attrapé de la folie et de la
haine je me suis dit mais j'arrête c'est
fini je ne veux plus retomber dans dans
cette relation c'est sauf qu'il peut la
vie quoi ouais euh Catherine vous dites
la haine dans le regard c'est dans les
mots ou simplement dans le regard c'est
quelque chose qui est indicible et que
seule une fille peut oui souvent le
maman me disait par exemple si tu
n'étais pas ma fille je te haïeris
bon ça je dire quand je vous entendez ça
plusieurs fois vous dit bon elle me quoi
et vous puisque vous avez bien un regard
là-dessus justement quelle explication
vous apportezv à la haine de votre mère
elle vous en veut de quoi d'après je
crois qu'elle m'en veut de vivre la vie
qu'elle aurait voulu avoir c'est que
maman a voulu être journaliste elle a
jamais été journaliste elle a failli
être journaliste et la dernière minute
elle a eu peur elle s'est dit que
c'était pas un métier sûr et elle a
préféré être fonctionnaire elle voulait
écrire elle a écrit beaucoup de
manuscrit elle écrit bien mais elle est
jamais arrivé à se faire publier or moi
j'écris je me fais publier euh et puis
ça va très très très loin je je pense
que euh souvent quand je suis en face
d'elle d'elle j'ai l'impression qu'elle
veut me me piquer je sais pas mon pull
mes cheveux mon mari mes enfants ma
maison euh j'ai on a l'impression que
et moi ce que je l'explique en pensant
qu'elle m'a eu à 20 ans et que elle a
rien eu le temps de vivre qu'elle s'est
retrouvé avec un petit bébé à 20 ans
qu'elle avait elle se prenait pour
Scarlette OARA parce qu'elle elle était
très belle très jolie elle avait tous
les garçons du monde à ses pieds qu'elle
était dans la séduction c'était une
femme qui était pas du tout dans dans
l'indépendance et l'affirmation de sa
personne était complètement dans la
séduction tournée vers l'autre et
qu'elle s'est retrouvé coincé à 20 ans
avec une petite fille en plus parce que
après j'ai appris plus tard qu'elle
voulait un garçon ce mot qui est fort
hein le mot de haine et vous l'avez
ressenti tout à coup ou j'imagine que
c'est c'était présent non tout au long
de votre enfance et de votre adolescence
comment ça c'était quoi vos relations en
fait tant que j'étais petite ça s'est
plutôt bien passé parce que je crois
qu'elle devait avoir l'impression
qu'elle me tenait
et donc elle me possédait j'étais sa
créature et et j'étais comme une pâte à
modeler et cela dit je me souviens qu'à
13 ans par exemple j'ai fait une fugue
j'en pouvais plus je suis partie j'ai
tout fait quoi Fall que je parte au bout
de de jours je l'ai appelé ou de d'un
jour je l'ai appelé je dis que j'étais
chez une copine et que je reviendrai pas
avant 15 jours j'avais vraiment besoin
de vivre à mon compte donc j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps à m'apercevoir qu'en
fait c'était elle qui ne m'aimait pas et
pas moi qui ne l'aimais pas vous voyez
parce que un enfant c'est vrai se
culpabilise je me disais si elle t'aime
pas c'est de ta faute donc je faisais
beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts et en fait
j'ai essayé de remplir un tonneau sans
fond parce que je faisais jamais les
choses comme il fallait quoi donc ça a
commencé comme ça petite et puis et
pourtant je faisais des études et j'ai
eu mon bac à 16 ans voyez j'étais
vraiment dans un rapport de de je
voulais attraper son regard voilà
j'arrivais jamais à attraper son regard
elle me regardait pas c'est terrible
pour une enfant de pas être regardé al
heureusement j'avais mon père à côté
alors ce qui est drôle c'est que mon
père qui a été entre guillemets un
mauvais père parce que il est parti
trompé maman tout le temps il oublié
payé la pension alimentaire enfin il
nous oubliéit nous chercher le dimanche
et en même temps c'est c'est lui qui m'a
donné l'amour et maman qui a tout fait
bien on a eu les chaussures
orthopédiques les appareils dentaires
les bonnes écoles on a pas pris
l'anglais le piano cétait très bien on a
eu la la la forme mais pas le fond on a
pas eu
l'amour mais en même temps c'est très
c'est très c'est très dur de s'en sortir
quand on est enfant parce que parce que
comment je pouvais aimer papa qui était
pas aimable et ne pas aimer maman qui
qui était aimable donc j'ai été coincé
entre les deux ça m'a pris très très
très très long long temps pour m'en
sortir c'est surtout là d'arriver à se
dire c'est pas parce que c'est ma mère
qu'elle va m'aimer et c'est pas parce
que c'est ma mère que je dois l'aimer
vous ne pensez pas que cet amour
justement qui énorme apparemment qui
vous liez à votre père a aussi d'une
certaine manière éloigné votre mère oui
moi je pense que forcément ça ça a
éloigné maman au bout d'un moment par ça
devait être très irritant que j'aime un
homme qu'elle n'aimait plus aussi ça
c'est bon mais c'est vrai que maintenant
qu'on en parle je me souviens qu'à la
maison c'était fou d'ailleurs il y avait
mon frère et maman d'un côté de la table
et mon père et moi puis un moment ils
sont divorcés donc moi je suis
restée dans la famille mais un peu en
pièce rapportée quand même puisque la
relation très forte c'était maman et mon
frère et papa et moi et du reste mon
père n'a jamais regardé mon frère et
maman n'a jamais voulu me regarder moi
donc c'était était pas à l'aise avec une
fille parce je crois que dès que je suis
arrivée j'étais une rivale pour elle
pour tout quoi tu vois quand elle parles
de moi petite fille elle m jour tu étais
une peste tutais méchante éit une peste
ta fille est beaucoup plus genie que toi
ce qui est terrible parce que on peut
pas dire qu'une petite fille est une
peste quoi cette rivalité avec vous elle
se manifestait comment
elle se manifestait alors quand j'étais
adolescente donc j'avais à peu près 15
ans elle en avait 35 on est habillé
pareil très souvent par exemple
j'achetais un truc court c'était la mode
c'était les années où on se mettait du
cours elle s'achetait une robe
courte et puis quand j'ai commencé à
avir des petits copains elle c'est vrai
qu'elle elle était très très charmante
avec elle
était il y avait un rapport qui était
pas normal avec ces ces garçons donc qui
qui avait 18 19 ans maman qui avait
quand même 39 40 c'est quoi une relation
pas normale c'està dire que par exemple
moi j'avis le droit d'amener mes petits
copains à la maison donc on dormait à la
maison et maman nous apporté le petit
déjeuner au lit le matin alors quand
j'ai quand j'avais cet âge là je
trouvais ça formidable parce que je me
disais c'est bien on n pas la galère
d'aller à l'hôtel ou d'aller dans les
voitures on va tous les trucs qu'on fait
quand on est adolescent ou jeune et
après je me suis rendu compte que elle
leur faisait autant de charme pas que
moi mais c'est vrai que je me rappelle
de scène où elle a porté le plateau du
petit-déjeuner et moi je reculais un peu
dans le lit et que c'était un dialogue
entre mon Jul et maman quoi elle a eu un
comportement de séduction aussi avec
votre mari plus tard ou avecou oui oui
ah ben oui c'està que moi je lui offrais
sur un plateau le prince charmant
qu'elle avait pas rencontré ce coup de
bol j'ai épousé quelqu'un d'ailleurs je
me suis demandé aussi pourquoi j'avais
épousé un Prin charmant c'était faire
plaisir à maman vous voyez elle a été je
le jourù je lui ai dit que j'aipousé ce
monsieur-là d'abord elle m'a dit c'est
pas possible non un type aussi bien ne
va pas t'épouser toi c'est pas c'est pas
non il y a une erreur de casting j'ai D
et mais c'est sans arrêt des scènes
comme ça quand j'ai eu ma petite
fille Charlotte elle elle est venue me
voir à la clinique donc deux ou TR jours
après donc on est dans espèce d'état de
Nirvana on tient son bébé on ne revient
pas d'avoir fait un bébé et elle rentre
dans la chambre elle regarde Charlotte
ça puis en partant elle m'a dit
maintenant tu vas connaître la haine
d'une fille pour sa mère et moi j'ai t
aimé ah oui dit c'est exprimé oui al ça
c'est ça que j'aime bien aussi che gel
vous savez c'est tellement exprimé qu'on
peut pas se tromper qu'il y a un moment
où ça on se dit bon c'est pas du non dit
et ce que j'aime beaucoup chez elle
c'est que c'est du dit quoi et ce que je
regrette c'est qu'on puisse pas pousser
toutes les deux le dit plus loin qu'on
puisse que je puisse pas lui dire écoute
tu m'aimes pas parce voilà pourquoi je
pense que tu m'aimes pas voilà pourquoi
je pense que j'étais obligé d'être
violent
et et voilà pourqui je je voudrais
t'aimer et voilà pourquoi tu devrais
m'aimer justement vous parliez de de vos
enfants vous avez été une une mère qui
avait un certain âge on va dire bon hein
vous avez eu votre premier enfant à 38
ans et le second donc 39 ans et demi
voilà est-ce que c'est parce que vous
aviez justement peur vous avez dû
attendre longtemps est-ce que c'est lié
à votre à votre vie avec elle c'est lié
à la fois aux deux c'est lié d'abord à
mon père à qui j'étais très très attaché
et puis AC qui j'avais un rapport aussi
aussi très très bizarre parce que papa
CIT pas simple non plus hein et puis oui
c'était pas simple du tout pas c'est pas
pour pour rien que j'ai fait un livre
sur lui quoi 350 pages de B mais c'était
aussi lié à maman parce que je me je
savais qu'elle m'avait pas aimé donc je
me disais j'arriveraai pas à aimer un
enfant moi comment je vais faire et
d'ailleurs Charlotte je suis restée un
an j'avais très très très très envie de
l'aimer mais je me disais je vais pas y
arriver comment on fait pour aimer un
enfant Catherine vous avez failli dire
d'ailleurs euh
je ne sais pas comment aimer vous avez
dit un enfant vous avez failli dire un
homme ah c'est pareil oui est-ce que ça
a été aussi difficile vous de d'aimer
justement un H je pense que c'est encore
plus dur un
homme parce que un homme il doit passer
à travers les le souvenir de la mère et
le souvenir du père comme moi j'ai eu
deux grands tueurs quand même comme
parents c'était des pas du tout dans le
même genre hein mais c'était des
spécialistes quand même de la chasse
armée pourquoi vous n'avez pas écrit un
livre aussi violent je dire à l'égarde
de votre mère vous auriez sorti tout ce
que vous aviez d'abord je j'ai écrit le
livre sur Papa parce qu'il était mort et
je pense qu' il faut pas écrire sur les
gens quand ils sont vivants par ça peut
quand même leur faire de la peine euh
c'est pour ça que je parle très très peu
en fait de de ma vie privée dans les
livres enfin si j'ai parlé de papa dans
les hommes cruels mais il était mort et
puis de toute façon maman je pourrais
écrire n'importe quoi sur elle je pense
qu'elle lirait pas elle ne lit pas mes
livres aucun elle a peut-être lu moi
d'abord parce que je passé apostrophe
donc ça tout d'un coup j'avais le saut
Bernard Pivot qui fait que on pouvait
lire ENF les autres sont passés
apostrophe elle a pas lu elle le fait
peut-être en cachette non elle ne vous
le dit pas pour vous pénaliser non al
non mais non non non elle est très fière
de pas les lire et je sais qu' un moment
la barbare elle allait le lire au
magasin réuni parce qu'elle travaillait
pas loin elle lisait quelques pages mais
elle voulait pas l'acheter surtout et
puis là le dernier vu de l'extérieur
elle a carrément pas lu elle a pas lu
elle a pas acheté euh je elle me parle
jamais de ce que je fais alors si elle
s'adresse à moi en tant que maman qui va
souffrir voilà elle voudrait que je je
répète le même schéma qu'elle on a des
discussions elle me dit mais pourquoi tu
travailles tu devais t'occuper de tes
enfants je dis mais attends moi je
deviens folle je travaille pas moi je me
suis sacrifié pour toi tu pourrais te
sacrifié pour tes enfants pourquoi moi
je me suis sacrifié pas toi et là je
veux plus quoi je ne veux plus repartir
dans cette souffrance je trouve ça trop
trop malsin quoi puis il y a un moment
où je me dis mais tu deviens Mazou quoi
tu te complets ça je peux pas je suis
jamais restée avec un homme qui me
faisait du mal je sais pas pourquoi je
vais rester avec une mère qui me fait du
mal c'est pas parce qu'on est au monde
des enfants qui vous appartiennent et
vous allez manipuler jusqu'à la fin de
leur vie et qu'on est obligé d'aimer ses
parents on n'est pas obligé d'aimer ses
parents et c'est pour ça que je suis
venue ici ce soir parce que je me suis
dit si je prends la parole en public vu
qu'elle lit pas mes livres je veux dire
là et encore je elle va pas la
regarderion elle le SAA c'est ça oui là
je me suis dit ça y est c'est définitif
la rupture est consommée je parle j'ai
l'impression que c'est un non retour
c'est une façon de dire parce qu'elle va
elle ne va pas vous pardonner d'en avoir
fait étap est tellement loin dans le
débit crédit que de toute façon je veux
dire j'ai tellement de débit chez elle
et j'ai rien en crédit donc je ve dire
ça va être un truc de plus le fait que
j'en parle je rond un tabou qui est le
tabou du silence et ça ça va être très
très dur pour elle mais je je pense
qu'elle va pas la regarder l'émission je
suis à peu près sûr mais parce qu'elle
est forte aussi elle est très très
costaud hein c'est quelqu'un de
terriblement dur mais bon tant pis moi
j'ai parlé j'ai dit ce que j'avais à
dire et puis maintenant c'est fini quoi
on passe à autre chose et et et c'est
pour ça du reste que je venu ce soir
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai jamais
écrit sur maman j'ai pas des personnages
de mère très sympathiques dans mes mais
je dis là ça y est c'est fini et puis
basta ci on en parle plus voilà est-ce
que le sens de votre témoignage n'est
pas aussi pour pour vos
enfants oui mais mes enfants en même
temps je l' oui oui euh c'estàd que ce
qui me frappe dans les familles c'est la
répétition ça ça c'est un truc qui
m'angoisse
terriblement quand je vois que j'ai une
fille d'abord et un petit garçon après
que moi je suis l'aîné que mes ENF et
que mon frère a 18 mois de moins que moi
comme Charlotte et Clément il y a des
trucs qui me ça me fout la trou il y a
des choses qui quand je vois que
Charlotte a exactement le même caractère
que moi je me dis il faut arrêter cette
chaîne de répétition donc c'est vrai que
je veux les protéger mais en même temps
je les protège en les élevant comme je
les élève vous croyez que tout le monde
est prêt à entendre Catherine ce que
vous venez de dire à savoir on n'est pas
obligé d'aimer ses parentses non je
crois que c'est un tabou quoi comme je
pense que on devient pas mère instant
anément que être mère c'est répéter donc
la la situation on était filles donc je
pense que c'est très dur et de la même
manière je pense qu'on est pas obligé
d'aimer sa mère si elle veut vous tuer à
chaque instant parce que là il y a c'est
plus votre mère quoi le la fonction des
parents c'est quand même de donner un
maximum d'amour pour que les enfants
soient indépendants et c'est comme le le
le pompisse qui met de l'essence dans
votre voiture elle roule et l'amour
c'est c'est l'essence que les parents
mettent dans le cœur des enfants et il
roulent après il roule pour s'en aller
on fait pas des enfants pour soi pour
dire regardez comme je suis belle et
intelligente parce que mes enfants ont
tout bon donc c'est pas vrai les enfants
c'est c'est séparé de vous alors mement
il fallait qu'on corresponde à sa vision
de la vie c'est terrible quand il faut
obéir à à à un moule quoi il faut alors
s moi ça pas marché du tout quoi ça a
été aussi là où on s'est affronté sans
arrêt c'est moi j'ai fait exactement ce
que je voulais parce que je crois qu'au
fond j'avais cet amour de papa qui me
qui me propulsait bon alors je caotais
je sortais à droite et à gauche je
sortais des rails quelquefois mais
j'avais la conscience que j'étais
puisque j'avais cet homme qui m'avait
regardé et aimé très très fort donc moi
j'ai été propulsée par cet amour c'est
une RRE de lancement l'amour du père et
la mère c'est ce qui vous donne votre
identité tout ce que vous dites en tout
cas il deux pôles qui sont importants
c'est d'être propulsé par l'amour et
d'avoir la reconnaissance quoi qu'il
arrive mot que vous avez utilisé c'est
ça c'est les parents qui respectent pas
leurs enfants je qui les qui les
reconnaissent pas comme individus je
parentière et je me souviens quand maman
me disait mais je comprends pas j'ai
tout fait pour toi et je lui disais mais
tu aurais mieux fait de respirer quoi de
pas étouffer de respirer elle elle a
étouffé pour nous elle s'est étouffé
elle vous aujourd'hui quelle mère vous
essayer d'être mais moi j'essaie de
faire l'opposé quoi donc je les écoute
énormément
euh et puis je leur explique par exemple
je leur dis que c'est pas évident d'être
une maman que on peut être énervé que là
je suis énervée là qui m'énerve vraiment
donc je je décode tout quoi mais que je
les aime je leur dis toujours mais je
vous aime là je suis fâchée avec toi
parce que tu as fait ça mais je t'aime
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Inna
Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche bonjour c'est Mireille Duma vous
apparaissez dans l'une de nos vidéos
vous désirez témoigner de nouveau
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter par mail
à l'adresse qui s'écrit ci desessous